خطه السلام الصينيه في اوكرانيا تقوم على
12 نقطه في مقدمتها تطبيق مبادئ ميثاق
الامم المتحده الخاصه باحترام سياده الدول
وعدم استخدام القوه والتهديد بها لضم
الاراضي ونبذو عقليه الحرب البارده هو عدم
السعي لتحقيق الامن القومي على حساب امن
الدول الاخرى والاهتمام بالمشاكل الامنيه
لكافه دول اوروبا الخطه ترتكز ايضا على
وقف القتال والصراع والتحلي بضبط النفس
تفاديا لتاجيج النزاع مع اطلاق مفاوضات
سلام وفتح باب الحل السياسي في اسرع وقت
ممكن الازمه الانسانيه لها حيز من الخطه
عبر دعم وتشجيع كافه الاجراءات التي تساهم
في تخفيف ازمه المدنيين وحمايه الاسرى
الخطه تدعو ايضا للحفاظ على سلامه المحطات
النوويه وتقليل من المخاطر الاستراتيجيه
من خلال معارضه استخدام الاسلحه النوويه
والكيماويه والبيول وجيه خارطه الطريق
الصينيه تدعو لضمان نقل الحبوب وتنفيذ
مبادره البحر الاسود وكذلك بالتوقف عن فرض
العقوبات احاديه الجانب مع ضمان استقلال
سلاسل الصناعه والامداد والحفاظ على
النظام الاقتصادي العالمي القائم لتخلص
الخطه لدعوه المجتمع الدولي الى الدفع
باعاده الاعمار بعد نهايه النزاع بلال
البجداني العربيه